pendant ce temps à paris mobilisation de
l'association droit au logement qui
réclame l'application de la loi
permettant d'attribuer d'office des
logements vides aux mal logés
une mesure prise par le général de
gaulle en 1945 et qui depuis n'a jamais
été appliquée le reportage de laurent
bay trois cent mille logements vides en
ile-de-france et des millions de
mal-logés pourtant un grand pas pourrait
être fait selon l'association droit au
logement
si on appliquait une loi de 45 qui
autorise la réquisition de logements
vides en cas de crise
une position au cumul nick mans partager
les coluche les restos du coeur parlait
de la nourriture des gens qui ont faim
qu'ils mangent pas céder les buts de
basa même pas une histoire politique
maintenant ils veulent faire une ville
de paris où il n'y a que des gens riches
alors il ya deux façons de faire pour
que les francs les parisiens soient
riches faire que tous les parisiens sont
enrichis ou faire que les parisiens
convoi disparaissent c'est la deuxième
solution et l'ars n'a été prise que l'on
ne craigne pas pour la propriété privée
nous sommes nous tous absolument plus
que mais peut-être encore plus dans
beaucoup d'autres pays attaché un au
droit de propriété
mais ne l'oublions g et ses droits
sacrés absolument à défendre est limité
il est limité par la nécessité publique
de toute façon ne sont visés que les
milliers de logements vides appartenant
aux entreprises publiques ou aux banques
et aux assurances en tout cas
aujourd'hui grande première depuis 30
ans la préfecture a accepté d'examiner
800 dossiers prioritaires